alright let's run a breaking news
tonight I promise we'll get it all in
it's a lot we start with this president
Trump is slamming the Attorney General
jeff Sessions for relying on an Obama
appointed inspector general to probe the
massive Faiz abuse scandal and not DOJ
lawyers who actually have real
prosecutorial power now the president
tweeted earlier today quote why is
Attorney General Jeff Sessions asking
the Inspector General to investigate
potentially massive FISA abuse well
we'll take forever has no prosecutorial
power and already late with reports on
Comey etc isn't the IG and Obama guy why
not use the Justice Department lawyers
then he writes this graceful then the
Attorney General well he responded he
put out a statement it reads quote we
have initiated the appropriate process
that will ensure complaints against this
department will be fully and fairly
acted upon if necessary as long as I'm
the Attorney General I will continue to
discharge my duties with integrity and
honor and this department will continue
to do its work in a fair and impartial
manner according to the law in the
Constitution in this case I believe the
president's right now we know from two
Republican memos and the shift' memo the
Democratic memo that the Clinton bought
and paid for dossier filled with Russian
government lies and propaganda was used
to spy on the Trump campaign we know
that we also know for a fact the FBI and
DOJ lied to a FISA judge about Clinton
in the DNC financing the dossier and
these memos show us that this FISA
application it never mentioned Hillary
or the DNC that she controlled they
never told the FISA judges now that is
called maliciously lying and purposely
deceiving FISA Court judges and justices
and here's what's worse the FBI and the
DOJ they did it four separate times one
for the original warrant to spy on
Carter page and then that warrant was
renewed on three separate occasions and
we have also discovered that yes the
Trump campaign was in fact spied on and
here's why when the FBI got approval for
that FISA warrant using her bought and
paid for dossier it also gave them
access to every one of Carter pages old
emails that
old text messages that means old phone
calls everything which dates back to
when he was a member of the Trump
campaign and then it gets worse
remember political reported that the
former top White House advisor Steve
Bannon he may have even been picked up
on FBI surveillance of page now this is
about immediate accountability this is
about the rule of law if you did this at
home I promise you you would be
investigated and probably be on trial by
now and government officials in the end
I predict are going to go to jail over
this so it is time knowing the facts as
we have them which are incontrovertible
and overwhelming that the Attorney
General has to do his job serve the
American people and yes the rule of law
in the Constitution and Jeff Sessions if
he's not up to the task if he wants to
create a two-tier justice system well we
have other options how about just
appoint a special counsel because that's
other breaking news tonight and all
brand-new Republican congressman they
are demanding that Jeff Sessions do that
very thing appointed special counsel to
investigate what is massive and widening
FISA abuse scandals these lawmakers also
want the Special Counsel to probe the
corrupt Clinton email investigation
remember the fix was in they were
writing the exoneration before
investigation and how the Trump Russia
investigation even started now we just
explained all the key details about
Obama era FISA abuses now here's what we
know about the so-called Clinton email
investigation we know the fix was in
from the beginning we know his
predetermined hillary was not going to
be charged even those that she had on
her email server which was unsecure and
a mom-and-pop bathroom closet and she
deleted emails acid-wash smashing
blackberries with a hammer all of that
they're all major crimes they would send
every one of you to jail out there every
one of course not named Hillary Clinton
for a long time it never happened why
not
now James call me Trump aiding FBI agent
Peter struck other top FBI officials
they started writing the exoneration
gave her the get out of jail free card
before doing their investigative work
and then there's of course the issue of
how the Trump Russia probe started
here's the information we currently have
the Trump aiding FBI agent Peters truck
who was a top counterintelligence
official
the paperwork that actually kicked off
this entire Russia witch-hunt struck his
FBI girlfriend mistress and by his
partisan lisa page there's corrupt as
they come and they talked about an
insurance policy with who we think is
the former FBI deputy director Andrew
McCabe remember that insurance policy
insurance policy in case of what Donald
Trump winning the American people
deciding they want him as their
president we also have new at this hour
Hillary Clinton has zero shame she is
actually pretending tonight to be
outraged she's feigning outrage and is
accusing president Trump of surrendering
to the Russians and she lashed out
earlier today in a tweet writing quote I
say this as a former Secretary of State
and as an American the Russians are
still coming our intelligence
professional professionals are imploring
Trump to act we will he continued to
ignore surrender or protect our country
okay
Obama new in 2014 this was going to
happen in 2016 he did nothing and
Hillary you couldn't be a bigger
hypocrite or more partisan hack do you
really have the audacity to lecture
anybody on Russia did you forget that
you are failed reset button that you
handed over to your counterpart or
uranium one giving 20% of America's
uranium to the hostile regime of Russia
the hostile actor Vladimir Putin or
maybe it was because you and Bill
oh let's see you doubled his speaking
fees in Moscow and then a hundred and
forty five million dollars flowing right
back into your foundation the people
involved in that deal or about how you
supported Barack Obama had did
absolutely nothing even though he was
warned again and again that he had to
stop Russia election interference oh and
Hillary there's also the dossier and the
evidence of real Russia collusion in the
campaign of 2016 and how you and the DNC
that you controlled forked over over
twelve million dollars for Russian lives
to lie to the American people on the
about to go into the ballot box on the
eve of an election really just a little
bit of free advice Hillary when it comes
to Russia maybe you just want to keep
your right to remain silent
and all
so tonight we have even more breaking
news it involves a very big question
here it is okay how do for Pfizer judges
that we now know tonight will lie to by
the FBI as it relates to the Clinton
dossier how do these judges feel about
being lied to
well tonight we have new information to
help answer that very question Sarah
Carter reporting that Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Court
presiding judge her name is rosemary
Collier
she told congressman Devon Nunez and
Congressman Bob Goodlatte in a February
18th letter that documents they are
requesting from the FISA Court can
actually be obtained from the DOJ with
the approval from the White House now in
her letter this is where it gets
interesting she writes that request for
FISA Court information related to the
approval of a FISA warrant to spy on
Carter page quote present novel and
significant questions novel significant
meaning knew never happened before
significant yeah this is pretty profound
and the judge adds that the court does
not have any problem with the executive
branch releasing any material from the
FISA Court to Congress here's my
takeaway sounds like this one judge and
probably the other three are now saying
we know pretty darn well we were lied to
we were manipulated but we have to now
go through the proper process to get the
truth out now that is a major
development we'll be following this
story very very closely also brand-new
tonight that clock is ticking for the
Obama administration those officials to
answer congressman Devin Nunez has ten
questions about the dossier the deadline
for the House Intelligence Committee the
chairman said is Friday at midnight and
what Devin Nunez is trying to find out
is what these Obama officials knew when
did they know it in regards to this
phony dossier now we know that the Obama
FBI DOJ State Department members of
Congress all either had the dossier or
were briefed on this phony dossier what
Nunez rightly is seeking are answers to
how these officials found out about the
dossier who told them about it and then
what they did with that information now
the Wall Street Journal their editorial
board they're raising some very
important serious questions and making
key points about the
dossier for example the editorial board
points out that if Hillary Clinton and
the DNC they're paying the twelve
million bucks for the dossier with
Russian source lies then fusion GPS
would have almost certainly shown them
what their money bought now former
Senate Minority Leader Harry Reid also
referenced what was in the dossier
remember this point he sent that letter
to James Comey at the end of October
2016
this was only days before the election
clearly the dossier was not some closely
held secret in terms of officials all
across the Obama administration
obviously knew about it Harry Reid knew
about it so it's now time for all of
them to respond and tell us you we the
American people what did they know and
when did they know it this dossier
scandal stretches well outside of the
Obama administration and 20 months after
Christopher Steele gave this phony fake
news dossier to the FBI believe it or
not we now have evidence that so many
liberals two years later are still
trying to prove it's true Russian
hookers ritz-carlton Moscow urinating on
bed there of that desperate The
Washington Times has put together a full
list
Rowen scarborough of all the liberal
players in this scandal that are
actually hoping they can verify anything
in this clinton bought and paid for
dossier here's a couple of examples
BuzzFeed remember they published the
dossier they're being sued for libel
they hired a retired FBI cyber expert to
try and corroborate these lies fusing
GPS also being sued for libel is is also
trying to still verify the dossier
former British by Christopher Steele
he's locked in a huge legal battle his
lawyers are reportedly they're trying to
confirm what he wrote in his own dossier
his own fake dossier verifying the
dossier is what BuzzFeed Fuzion GPS
steel should have actually done in the
first place
not to manipulate the American people
just a couple of months before the
election they never bothered to verify
it because to them it didn't matter it
was always about smearing then candidate
now President Donald Trump now finally
tonight a major report from the Daily
Caller
this is interesting and we're going to
follow this very very closely as
relates to James commis very
questionable leadership at the FBI and
the daily calls reporting quote the
Department of Justice's Inspector
General sanctioned at least 14 FBI
agents and officials for a range of
improper sexual acts since 2014 and most
of the conduct yes it occurred during
former FBI director Comey's term and
here's what's most troubling the Daily
Caller reports that the DOJ Inspector
General were waiting any day now Michael
Horowitz found that Comey actually
attempted to interfere with the
investigation we reached out to James
Comey for comment shockingly he never
got back to us I bet he's probably
watching this is just another example of
how corrupt James Comey really is he's a
national embarrassment he's a disgrace
to law enforcement he deserved to be
fired and we will follow this closely I
can't wait for this book to come out
because he's so sanctimonious on Twitter
tick-tock